vincent maréchal professeur et
spécialiste en virologie bonsoir vincent
maréchal merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france voudrait qu'on
s'arrête quelques instants tout d'abord
sur un chiffre qui attire nécessairement
l'attention
jérôme salomon qui nous disait que 921
patients en réanimation sur la moitié de
ces patients en qui sont dans un état
grave
la moitié ont moins de 60 ans on c'est
vrai que c'est une information
importante parce que c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on nous avait dit au début de
cette épidémie on disait en gros c'est
voilà c'est une un virus qui qui
frappent sévèrement les plus âgés ce
n'est plus du tout le cas alors je sais
pas j'ai pas accès au dossier de ses
patients donc je sais pas exactement
quel est leur profil s'il ya des
comorbidités je rappelle qu'il n'y a pas
que l'âge qui est un facteur important
il ya aussi on le sait une certaine
fragilité bon lahlimi nos super
l'immunodépression est un facteur
favorisant des gens qui ont compris des
traitements comme des anti
inflammatoires beaucoup parlé du
prophète également il ya quelques temps
on parle aussi de problèmes de surpoids
de diabète donc il faudrait vraiment
avoir accès à des informations
complémentaires sur ces sur ces gens
jeunes pour savoir s'il faut s'en
inquiéter ou pas mais c'est vrai que la
moitié ça semble beaucoup de ça ne vous
fera pas vous en tant que professeur de
médecine
je suis pas professeur de médecine je
suis virologues enjeux scientifiques
donc moi je regarde les faits voilà je
regarde les faits et j'essaye de
m'appuyer sur ce qui est publié
ou ce qui est décrit sur ces cas là moi
j'ai pas l'information aujourd'hui donc
il faudrait demander à pas les
cliniciens décidé d'éclairer un certain
nombre de ces dossiers on sait qu'il
peut y avoir des facteurs de
susceptibilité génétique aussi ça a été
décrit notamment dans les formes graves
de grippe
encore une fois on a des hypothèses il
faut il faut commencer par analyser
calmement les dossiers évacuer les
facteurs de comorbidité et puis après
faire d'autres hypothèses si c'est
nécessaire
alors le bilan
jour malheureusement 9134 cas de 164
décès soit 89
de plus vous attendez beaucoup de ces
mesures de confinement qui ont débuté
hier
alors je préfère qu'on prenne le
problème à linverse faut que les gens
comprennent que on est à un stade où le
virus circule maintenant de façon très
libre et que les gens qui sont infectés
aujourd'hui ne le savent pas tous et ça
c'est un point qui est très important il
ya une part non négligeable de porter
long symptomatique
il y a également sans doute des gens qui
se plaignent d'avoir des irritations des
maux tête des signes qu'on appelle ici
grippaux mais qui sont pas très
spécifiques et parmi tous ces gens qui
n'iront pas se faire détester qui
n'iront pas qu'ils ne rentreront pas
dans l'est dans les systèmes de
surveillance il ya effectivement le
potentiel de transmettre le virus donc à
plusieurs façons de faire soit on fait
un test généralisée chez tous les
porteurs und isolde c'est ce qu'on a
fait au début c'est ce qui s'est fait
dans certaines régions du monde
c'est un système qui est très
contraignante très coercitif qui est
très conservateur en moyens l'autre
solution c'est de dire que pour que les
gens arrêtent de se contaminer all is
isole donc on isole aujourd'hui à
l'échelle de la famille à l'échelle du
regroupement familial et on évite les
contacts entre des gens qui
potentiellement sont affectés mais ne le
savent pas et les gens qu'il pourrait
croiser dans la rue donc le ce cette
séparation physique reste larmes la plus
simple pas forcément à mettre en place
mais la plus simple au moins en termes
de compréhension pour casser cette
circulation du virus donc on va voir
d'ici quinze jours trois semaines s'il
ya un premier effet à mon avis ça risque
d'être un peu court faudra sans doute
attendre un petit peu plus longtemps
pour voir si ces mesures sont efficaces
il ya encore qu'elles soient
efficacement aussi alors justement l'om
s indique le confinement va freiner mais
pas éradiquer cette maladie et comme
vous l'avez évoqué à l'instant qu'il
vaudrait mieux tester tout le monde
votre avis pourquoi on ne le fait pas en
france par manque tout simplement de
moyens en le test il faut comprendre ce
qu'on en fait du test le test on l'a
on s'est inscrit dans une stratégie dans
lequel le test a été utilisée au début
pour très tôt identifié les gens qui
rentraient sur le territoire pour
pouvoir les isoler et ensuite pour
isoler les clusters identifier les
clusters pour la circulation s'est faite
sur des petites zones
donc tant qu'on avait les moyens
logistiques de tester les gens de les
isoler ça valait la peine
aujourd'hui on part du principe que le
virus circule déjà beaucoup plus 1,2 de
façon beaucoup plus importante que les
chiffres qu'on a là les 9130 15 c'est
les cas qu'on a détecté mais il ya
encore beaucoup de cas probablement qui
circulent sur le territoire le plus
simple aujourd'hui est effectivement de
mettre en place des mesures barrières et
on le voit qu'elles ont eu des effets
très positifs en chine en particulier
puisque les chinois nous déclare
quasiment plus de cas l'épidémie et est
considérablement ralentie si ce n'est
ses traits de quasiment bloqué en chine
et une étude qui a été publié
aujourd'hui où il ya quelques jours par
l'impérial college de londres montre
également que ces mesures barrières et
l'accumulation de ces mesures barrières
de ces mesures de confinement la
fermeture des lieux publics reste une
approche à développer pour essayer de
ralentir encore une fois la circulation
du virus alors il y aussi ça peut ça
peut choquer qu'on n'essaye pas de
bloquer totalement la circulation du
virus mais faut expliquer ce qui selon
ce qu'on entend par là aujourd'hui
l'urgence c'est de faire en sorte que
les cas les plus problématiques ne
s'accumule pas dans des très courte
période de temps dans les services de
réanimation
donc l'idée c'est dans un premier temps
de diminuer le nombre de cas déclarés
par jour de manière à ce que nos
collègues les les réanimateurs les
infirmières et personnels de soins dans
les hôpitaux et le temps de gérer et de
prendre en charge correctement
l'afflux très important de patients donc
l'idée est de ralentir mais on sait que
la rançon de ce ralentissement c'est le
fait que l'épidémie la durée cet aller
plus dans le temps justement vous pariez
la chine désormais l'europe compte plus
de victimes qu'en chine ça encore on
explique comment
ah bah on est on est dans des situations
dans des situations très différentes
il ya un paramètre qui ne faut jamais
oublier c'est que les épidémies ont un
temps d'examen point de départ un point
d'arrivée que c'est à vous à nantes
chine que c'est que ce que kaka démarrer
l'épidémie mais c'est aussi l'endroit
dans lequel on avis le plus tôt en place
des mesures très coercitives à la
population chinoise ça a vraiment subi
une des mesures de confinement très très
sévère et donc à la chine a été en
avance tout simplement à la russie à
mettre en place des mesures très dures
et puis secondaires mandéka partie de
chine sont à l'essai mais un peu partout
dans le monde et ont créé des faux crée
des foyers secondaires donc nous fait
partie de ces foyers secondaires
tertiaires dont l'épidémie est en train
de ralentir dans certaines zones du
monde et de repartir sur un mode plus
plus exponentielle à d'autres endroits
dont l'italie la france et d'autres pays
ont regardé la carte aujourd'hui du
monde allez on voit qui est assez peu de
zones qui sont qui sont épargnés
une dernière petite question rapide en
parle de vaccins aux états unis de
chloroquine ce sont des pistes qui donne
beaucoup d'espérance qui vous donnent
beaucoup d'espérance en tant que
virologue alors on peut on peut dire
qu'il faut il faut voir que la
problématique du vaccin doit être
dissocié de la problématique des
antiviraux les antiviraux les molécules
antivirales on parle de la chloroquine
mais y en a d'autres qui sont en cours
d'évaluation sont des molécules qu'on
espère pouvoir donner très rapidement
aux patients à la fois pour éviter les
formes graves et il faut pas l'oublier
également pour diminuer l'excrétion du
virus et donc rendre les gens qui est
secrète du virus moins contagieux pour
leur environnement d'encadrement 2-2
effet à l'utilisation de ces temps ces
antiviraux donc ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on est en train de tester maintenant
on prend des molécules qu'on connaissait
qui n'était pas forcément toutes des
antiviraux à 7k de la chloroquine
elle était utilisée comme un
antipaludéen on la teste on a espoir que
la chloroquine donne de bons résultats
mais d'autres molécules encore une fois
son sont en cours d'évaluation dans des
essais cliniques
on ne pourrait imaginer les données
assez rapidement pour donc bloqué à la
fois les formes les plus graves et aussi
réduire la circulation du virus
le vaccin c'est un autre problème le
vaccin c'est un processus plus long
s'inscrit dans une durée de un an à 18
mois d'après d'après les experts il ya
une trente 30 à 40 entreprises ou
groupes qui travaillent sur la
production de vaccins dans le monde donc
à une recherche qui est tout à fait
important et l'idée c'est plutôt d'avoir
un vaccin
quand dans six mois un an si le virus
est toujours là on est bien on est
quelque chose sous la main pour bloquer
la circulation du virus
si jamais il n'est pas pas totalement
pas totalement sous contrôle donc les
antiviraux c'est la barrière
d'aujourd'hui c'est celle qu'on peut
dans les semaines qui viennent ou les
mois qui viennent espérer se voir mettre
en place le vaccin lui ces 12 18 mois
n'est pas dans la même stratégie
merci beaucoup vincent maréchal d'avoir
été avec une professeur de virologie à
l'université merci à vous